[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANGELA FORD: Thank you.
Let's get right to it.
The Obsidian Collection--
the term obsidian
comes from a volcanic rock.
It's a dark glass
that's formed when
lava and dirt, certain
explosions, all of that
come about.
So there are lots of
obsidian around Hawaii
and other places where
there are volcanoes.
I love the name because I think
that's what black culture is--
beautiful, black, shiny formed
from high pressure, heat, et
cetera.
And that's what we're doing--
The Obsidian Collection, we're
collecting the black archives.
But more than just that,
we're digitizing them
and making them available
for younger generations.
And as I started the
project just a little bit
over three years ago, we were
asked, why are you doing that?
There's already archive groups
that are collecting history,
the universities
are collecting it,
and we got that big, beautiful
new black Smithsonian in DC,
so why do you need to form
The Obsidian Collection?
And I think I can best
communicate that in telling you
about my love of football.
Now, I know.
It's going to work
its way back around.
But I love football.
I love Chicago Bears football.
And I can tell you, from when
I was five to seven years old,
my dad's friends
would come over,
we had a giant floor
model TV, and they
would let me get the
beer and they would
let me empty the ashtrays.
Now, this is the
late 60s, early 70s,
so beer cans were
made of what I would
think was solid titanium
steel and the ashtrays
were these huge
ceramic platters.
So my responsibility
was important.
I remember the
screens being green,
there being white
lines on the screen,
people would crash
into each other,
and then my father
and his friends
would either cheer or jeer.
And it was football.
And I love football.
Now, fast forward, I
started seeing football
throughout my life and I
know how football works.
The X's and O's line up, then
they crash into each other.
And then somebody
throws in a yellow towel
and then people stand around
like this and then they wait
and then the guys in the stripes
come out and do some things.
And then they either say
this way or they say that way
and then you cheer or jeer.
Now I've been watching
football my whole life.
I would argue with
you that I love
football just like
any other American
and I love the Chicago Bears,
I'm a native Chicagoan.
But imagine if I was the
curator of the Chicago Bears.
I would put together an
exhibit and it would be
all of the collisions, right?
Because that's what
they kind of do,
they run into each other a lot.
They line up, and then
they run into each other.
And then somebody
throws the towel--
I've seen it.
So, what I would do is I
would have an exhibit of all
the collisions.
And then I would have another
exhibit of the towels,
because they went from
a mustard and then they
started being more yellow--
I do remember that.
And then I know in some
of the bigger games,
they pour containers
of water on each other
at the end of big wins--
I do know that too.
It doesn't make a lot of sense,
but that happens in football--
and I love football.
So one of my exhibits is going
to be all the coolers of water
dunking on people because
that's football to me
and I love football.
Now, somebody who actually likes
football would go to my exhibit
and inside of 15 seconds
they would go, what is this?
And this isn't football,
there are layers to football
and there's a whole ecosystem
and culture around football.
And this isn't football.
And that's what happens with
a lot of African Americans
that walk into an exhibit
and go, what is this?
It's people who just
focus on the collisions.
So you just hear picket,
protests, slave, struggle--
and it's like, look, there
are layers to this thing.
This isn't the sum total
of the black experience.
And just like me with
football, and this is true
because that is my
understanding of football,
I would say, well,
explain football to me.
And then people who
know football like Luke
you just don't know football and
you can't be in charge of it.
It's OK that you
think you love it
or whatever your association
is with it, that's
not the sum total of football.
And I remember my
senior year of college,
the Bears went to
the Super Bowl.
And I watched it with everybody
and again, they lined up--
I don't know what
the problem is,
because that's what happened--
they lined up, there was a
snap, somebody ran this way,
they ran into each other,
somebody threw in the towel.
This is what I
see and I love it,
but I loved
everything around it.
I'm football adjacent.
I should not be in charge of
telling the story of football.
So, it was then when one of
my friends said after we won--
I know we won, I do know that,
that we won that Super Bowl.
One of my friends
said, who do you
think is going to be the MVP?
I didn't know what an
MVP was, but everybody
burst into conversation
and they started
discussing these plays
and these little nuances
and all of this other stuff.
And that's when I
realized, I don't know
what they're talking about.
And that's how black culture is.
You can be adjacent
and you can love it,
but there's a lot
of layers to it.
And it's important that there
be an independent, free-standing
organization run by black
people to curate that story.
Because we can walk
into an exhibit and go--
I get it, it's a protest,
struggle, a slave,
it's a lynching--
it's like that's
all that's there.
So it's important for us
to take the narrative back
and that's what The Obsidian
Collection is doing.
So, we started with
The Chicago Defender.
Now, many people
know, and I don't
want to preach to the choir,
but The Chicago Defender
started in 1904 and it's
essential to black history
because as we were
freed as slaves,
people wanted to
start migrating away.
And The Chicago Defender was
different from other newspapers
and they took the initiative
to actually start getting
these newspapers down south.
So they partnered with
the Pullman porters
and the Pullman porters were,
in a way to make extra money,
they were distributing
and selling
the papers when in down
south, it was kind of frowned
upon for black people to
actually even read, let alone
get the scoop on where to go.
So The Chicago Defender actually
helped show black Americans
what was going on in
the rest of the states,
where they should go,
where safe passage was,
what to dress like when you
come up north, what to wear,
all of those good things came
through The Chicago Defender.
And The Chicago
Defender had sold--
the original family from 1904--
sold the paper in about 2007.
The theory was that all of the
images were taken by the family
and then some were given
to the library, some
to Getty, et cetera, and there
weren't that many images left.
So, when we came
there, we thought
there were going
to be 10,000 images
and we found actually 250,000
images in this one room.
And what happened
to me was you can't
see 250,000 images of yourself
and ever be the same, right?
So it was like being bit
by a radioactive spider.
We said, we got to get
this information out.
And I've learned
through my own child
that young people get everything
through the smartphone.
So, when I was telling my
son about some of the stories
and some of the
things we found, he
would go right to a
smartphone and say, well
that's not in here.
And are you spelling it right?
And I remember in
my own naivety,
I thought when the internet was
invented that everything was
automatically on the internet.
Like, well now it's
on the internet
now through some kind of magic.
What I came to learn was
we weren't digitizing
the black newspapers, the
black photojournalists
weren't getting-- there just
weren't specific platforms
to get the information
out there so that younger
and future generations
can immediately access it.
So, that's one of
the things we started
with The Chicago Defender.
The Chicago Defender
was our first effort
and now we have a lot
of black newspapers
in the queue to share their
images so we can get them out,
so that everybody can see them
and tell fabulous new stories.
So, John mentioned, we have
a wonderful partnership,
our first immediate platform
is through Google Arts
and Culture, who we met through
the Black Googler Network.
And we started by just
putting up some images.
Now, these are just three
of a quarter of a million.
And so I narrowed it
down, you're welcome.
But the first image I like
a lot because it's just
one of the secretaries
when The Chicago
Defender moved their offices
into the South Loop of Chicago.
That's an important play.
That story is on the Google
Arts and Culture Obsidian page
and it's a series of images.
But just being able
to accomplish a feat
like that back in those
days, and then there
were printers in the basement
and all of those other feats,
those are the kind of
plays that we would
discuss amongst ourselves.
That's the narrative of
how we see ourselves.
Aside from just the newspapers
and the photographers,
we've got small community
archives joining us.
And so the other picture,
the opposite one,
is of Fred Hutchinson
with a plane.
Wonderful story of this guy
who wanted to fly planes,
but as a black man in the early
1920s, that was a non-starter.
But his family was
a family of means,
so his father bought
him an airplane.
And so he learned how to
fly by starting the plane,
getting in it, and
flying it and landing.
You know, that happened.
And that was a small plane,
a single engine plane.
But he wanted to learn how
to fly a commercial airplane,
so he moved to Canada and he
joined the Royal Canadian Air
Force where he learned.
Then he eventually
moved to Haiti
and opened up a
black flight school.
But by then, we were
entering World War
II and America had
decided we're going
to need some black pilots.
So he actually became
a flight instructor
for the Tuskegee Airmen.
So, that story is from
Shorefront Legacy Archives.
They've been
collecting the history
of the black people who lived
on the Gold Coast in the 1900s.
That's a story that doesn't get
told, but it was a lot of them.
And that was 120 years
ago, but we were there too.
So, Shorefront has a
great archive and now
the Obsidian platform,
they've joined us,
and we'll be able to get
those stories to the world.
The one in the middle, it's
just one of my favorite photos
because it's just black boy joy.
I raised a black son in
Chicago and the kids have fun,
but that's not the narrative
that's in the mainstream.
But my life was
fun, my son's life
was fun-- if he says
it's not, he's lying.
It was amazing.
I was an awesome parent.
But we've got a ton
of images like that.
This is one of my
favorites and this
is helps me communicate that
I'm not doing this alone
because I'm not an archivist.
They will let you know that.
That's a postgraduate
degree industry,
I am not an archivist.
I am not a historian, they
will let you know that too.
And that's a PhD process.
So, what I am is a storyteller.
But I've aligned with experts
and we're creating new experts.
This picture, the man
with the hat is Joe Lewis,
he's a famous boxer.
And I knew he was a boxer
because when I was a kid,
we drink Joe Lewis milk.
And on the cover, he
was posing like this
and he had on boxing gloves,
so I knew he was a boxer.
I didn't know he was one
of the most famous boxers
ever, blah, blah, blah,
but that's Joe Lewis.
The guy in the middle--
Judge Duke Slater.
Duke is the first
African-American lineman
to play in the NFL.
And that story doesn't
get that much coverage.
I will spare you--
long and short, in
the NFL in 1926,
he's got one of
the best records,
it was just broken
recently by a Chicago Bear.
But the NFL let five
black people play in 1926,
then they hokey pokey-ed it back
and said, no, no black players.
So it went down, it was five,
then it went down to zero.
So, he was the first head coach
and formed the Chicago Negro
All-star football team.
And after he retired football--
and there's this long
story about that,
but we'll get those
narratives out there
because it's a good story.
In 1928, he actually
got his law degree.
So, after he retired
from football,
he became an assistant
district attorney
and then he's the second
elected judge in Chicago.
That is an important
part of our narrative,
we've got to get
those stories out
there so that this
is second nature.
But the picture in the
defender archives, on the back
it was written Judge Duke
Slater and Joe Lewis.
So I put that on Google Arts and
Culture, that's it, those two.
So, one of my friends
called me who's
60 and he said, why don't
you credit the other guy?
Now, people of a certain
age know who that is, right?
You know that is.
I didn't know who that was.
And it wasn't
written on the back.
Because you know
my love of sports,
but I won't bury the
lead too much longer,
that's Jackie Robinson.
Now, I only know one
image of Jackie Robinson
as the one that's on the
trading card when he was 24.
And so my friend
said, I going to need
you to write Jackie
Robinson's name up there.
And I said, but it doesn't say
Jackie Robinson on the back,
and that's not how
you're supposed to do it.
You're supposed to record
the history that is accurate.
And he said, you
know, Ang, anybody
with a pulse of a
certain age wouldn't
have thought to need to
write Jackie Robinson's name.
So, I will tell
younger people, it's
like if you had 100
pictures of LeBron James,
you wouldn't feel the
need to make sure you
wrote his name on every page.
But fast forward 50
years later, some child
that has not been born
yet is going to go
wasn't no name on there.
So, we threw that out.
So, I asked five other
people who were over 60,
do you know who this is?
And they were looking
at me like, is this--
because you know
who that is, right?
And I was like,
well, I'm just trying
to see if you know, you know,
before we actually put Jackie
Robinson's name on there.
But the other beauty about
this photograph is these
were three captains of sports--
boxing, football, and
baseball, and they
were actually playing
golf because Joe Lewis
made serious inroads
into Pro-am and the PGA.
And so this, for black people
who know sports better than I,
but you know, I know football,
these kinds of stories
and these pictures--
they knew they
were taking an iconic photo.
And we've got to make sure that,
not only do we get the photo,
but we've got to get
the elders involved
to make sure we get the
good intel on there.
Because I know everything else
really well except sports.
But we also have added more
than just photo journalism
and history.
Fashion and beauty
photographer Ernest Collins
loaned us 120 images that
we put up for Black History
Month this year.
So, on our Google
Arts and Culture page,
we've added a lot of
fashion and beauty
specifically because
that's part of our history.
The key part of that is we also
want to alter the metadata.
So when you go and Google
black man in Chicago,
primarily what's being populated
are news outlets and crime.
So you only get images
from 1940, if you're lucky,
but you mainly get crime.
So it's important
that as The Obsidian
uploads all of this metadata
onto the internet when
you type in black man,
black woman, all this--
we're going to be populating
it with hundreds of thousands
of images that are not the
collisions, because that's
already been done.
So we're picking the real
intricacies of the culture,
the layers to this game.
So let's get back to reclaiming
the Chicago narrative
and let's talk
about Bronzeville.
I'm going to go over what
a lot of people know,
maybe others don't.
But this is one of
my favorite photos.
So we don't own this
one, this was actually
owned by the
Library of Congress.
And it's completely royalty
free, it was shot in 1940--
about 1941.
And to most of
us, this is the go
to photograph for Bronzeville.
But this was just a
photographer coming
to hear another narrative
about how Bronzeville was,
but he just stopped
five ordinary boys
who were on their way to
Sunday school and said,
take a picture in
front of this car.
Because that's what
Bronzeville looked
like if we're
writing this story.
This is just another
day in the life,
everybody dressed like that.
All of the images from
my childhood, that's
what they looked like.
So, Bronzeville was
called the black belt,
but there was also a
restrictive covenant.
So, as we were moving in
droves from about 1916
forward, 1916 and 1948,
it was a law on the books
that black people could
only live in a specific area
and that was called the
restricted covenant.
So we all piled
into Bronzeville.
It's not the Bronzeville
proper today, it's about seven
of those neighborhoods and it's
a big part of the South Side.
So, with the black
belt, somehow we
had three hospitals,
six newspapers, 1000
small black-owned businesses,
2000 people worked
in the numbers game, and we
were three times more densely
populated than the
rest of Chicago.
So if you picked a certain
series of blocks in North Side,
there'd be 20,000 people.
That same we have
footage in Bronzeville--
60,000.
So we were piled in.
But it wasn't what the narrative
I've been reading kind of
leads us to, it was vibrant.
So we had the Jones department
store, we had the Palm Tavern,
we went to the
theaters, we had clubs--
Bronzeville was really
extremely exciting, populated,
and vibrant.
I'm stunned at this
current narrative
that kind of implies--
again, just collisions of I
don't know, they came here
and gosh, we got to help them.
And it's like, wait you're
leaving something out.
So we've got to get that online
so you guys can go to it.
What I love about the youth
culture is somebody puts
out a fact, you guys
clap back so fast
with all kinds of
facts and links
and hyperlinks it's like
boom, boom, boom, boom.
And so we've got to get
this information digitized
so that you can clap back
against these negative stories.
I don't know if it's that
they are black adjacent
or if it's malicious.
I don't know, but the
truth will set us all free.
And easy, quick access to
the truth will get us there.
So, I'll leave the
clap back to you guys
because I can't text
that fast, but we'll
get the information out there so
that you can have access to it.
But I was trying to figure
out, how did we do all of that
without all of this help that
has become the new narrative?
Like, oh my goodness,
if we don't help them
by eliminating their
entire culture,
then they won't be helped.
So, what we also did was form
what we call the Elder Circle.
And we started talking to
people from Bronzeville,
we started interviewing and
filming them and talking
to them getting the nuances
of what's happening in Chicago
and what happened
back in those days.
Now, the guy in the corner is
not of that same generation.
He's Nathan Thompson who wrote a
book called "The Policy Kings,"
and actually, we'll be
doing a documentary,
we'll be doing film--
there's a lot that
will be going on
that we'll be explaining
why Bronzeville was vibrant.
And it was mainly because
of the number runners.
Now, I'll say this--
because I don't give that story
away because that's coming--
but essentially,
those were the guys
who ran the numbers which
is like the lottery.
I think it's important
when I'm telling the story,
I'm starting a
narrative of 1746,
the New York General
Assembly had a lottery
and they built King's
College, which went on
to become Columbia University.
So when somebody else
is telling the story,
a lottery is acceptable.
But when we did
lottery, it became
thuggery and illegal and
illicit and all of those things.
That's why it's important to
drive your own narratives.
But the policy kings
lived in the community
and they actually
invested in the community.
And if you want to just
open up a small business,
you would get a small business
loan from a policy king
so that's how we were able to
be vibrant and self-sufficient.
So, I want to make
sure that we get
that information to you guys.
So that's kind of
the overview of what
The Obsidian Collection
is and why we're doing it
and what it is.
So, to take that forward, I am
going to invite my colleague--
my young colleague-- who has
been amazing and bold in that
she is one of the
co-founders of The Tribe,
and they are a digital platform
that speaks to millennials.
I'll say this, when
I saw it, I was
like, I don't know who
some of these people are.
My son was like, oh I know
who all these people are.
And he immediately
joined the tribe.
I've joined it too, but I'm
going to bring Morgan up
to the stage.
So let's give Morgan a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: Thank you.
ANGELA FORD: Thank you.
So, first I want
to ask you to tell
everyone what is The Tribe?
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: Sure.
So, The Tribe is a publication
and production company
with a mission to reshape the
narrative of black Chicago.
And we were born
out of resistance
to the dominant
narrative of Chicago--
the dominant narrative
of black Chicago--
ANGELA FORD: Right.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
--which is that we
are a violent,
throwaway community,
and especially black
millennials and youth,
that we are not
invested in or that we
don't care about black
lives which is a gross lie.
So I did a crazy thing and I
said I can't take it anymore.
I can't continue
to watch the news
and see black bodies
on the ground.
I can't continue to
read the newspapers
and see sensationalist headlines
about what the body count was
this weekend.
And I called one
of my best friends
who I went to Northwestern with
and I said, what can we do?
She's a journalist
and I talked to her
and I said, why don't you quit
your job at your newspaper,
move back to Chicago, and write
about what you care about.
And that's what we did.
ANGELA FORD: Is that Tiffany?
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
That's Tiffany, yeah.
ANGELA FORD: Because what I
love about you guys' logo is
it's forward, it's
progressive, it's young,
and it's, I guess, The Tribe.
Why did you call it The Tribe?
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: We
needed it to feel communal
and we wanted black Chicago
to feel like, this is ours.
We are finally taking
back our narrative.
ANGELA FORD: I want
you to talk about--
that's Tiffany,
that's in the middle,
and tell me who the
other gentleman is.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
That's David,
he's our web developer
and designer.
So he's the one that
came up with that logo.
And it's funny
because I actually
pushed back with him on it.
And then he said, I thought you
wanted to do news different.
And I was like, you
know what, you're right.
We're not going to look like
your typical mainstream media
platform.
This is going to
look like a movement,
we're going to brand it,
it's going to be a lifestyle.
Yeah.
ANGELA FORD: Well, that's great.
One of the things
when I met Morgan,
I was so moved by
the entrepreneurship.
It reminds me of all
of the entrepreneurship
that I've learned in the
archives and in the history,
but one of the things
I wanted to make
sure everybody understood, one
of the platforms you guys did
was Chi Vote.
Can you tell us about that?
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: We're
a small collective, really.
There really is three of us.
And so many people think that
we're this huge conglomerate,
but really we hire
freelancers and we
hire black voices to
help tell these stories
about black Chicago, but
at our core we thought,
there's no way that
we're going to be
able to take on the
elections with all the
5 million candidates
that there are.
So what can we do?
So I said, why
don't we reach out
to other independent
platforms and say,
can we come together and
amplify each other's stories
so that we're not
duplicating the same efforts
and then create an
election guide together?
And that's what we did.
So we reached out to the
Better Government Association,
Chicago Reporter, The
Daily Line, Block Club Chi,
Southside Weekly, a
bunch of organizations
to put together this
nonpartisan election guide.
So it's chi.vote.
ANGELA FORD: That's great.
What do you think that
The Obsidian, the platform
that we're building, which
should launch later this year,
how do you think those tools can
help what you guys are doing?
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: Well,
we have the same mission.
It's all about reshaping
the black narrative.
Black youth are not being told
the truth about who we are.
It's not taught in schools.
There's no way for us to
find some of this information
really until we get to college.
When we get to college,
that may be the first time
that we start reading
texts by black authors.
So when I think
about the news and I
think about 100
years from now, what
are people going to
go to reference what
black Chicago is right now?
Can you really look
at the archives
of The Tribune or
anywhere and say
this is a full picture of
what black Chicago is when
the majority of
that is going to be
headlines about who was slain?
So, we see The
Tribe as someone--
and The Obsidian
Collection-- as someone
who can step in and say,
here is a more holistic,
multifaceted view of
who we are as a people.
ANGELA FORD: That's great.
I think what I was hoping
to make sure we accomplish
is that people can get involved
and follow The Tribe and all
of that.
But tell me one
of the fun stories
or one of the important
stories that you guys
covered as The
Tribe that mattered
to you-- that sticks out,
because I know they all matter.
MORGAN ELISE
JOHNSON: Sure, sure.
So we have a series on
our site called Out West.
Tiffany, who is the
co-founder of The Tribe
and the Editor in Chief,
she's from North Lawndale.
It's--
[APPLAUSE]
OK, West Side.
But, you know, everybody talks
about the stories of the South
Side because there's so many
kind of vibrant, middle class
communities.
But people just leave the
West Side of the dialogue
completely when it
comes to west Chicago.
And so we wanted to
focus on a series
that talks about Tiffany's
roots to the West Side
and also the great migration and
that journey to the West Side
and why the West Side is kind
of like the city's forgotten
stepchild.
So we actually journeyed
to Mississippi together.
We found out, Tiffany and
I, that our families are
both from Bolivar
county and so we
went there to kind
of discover the past,
and isn't very
fascinating story.
If you look at this series
about us as young people
discovering who we
are by retracing
the roots of our grandmothers.
ANGELA FORD: So you use a lot
of things more than just text--
you use videos and you
create documentaries.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
Oh, absolutely.
So my background is
that I'm a filmmaker.
And so while Tiffany is your
more traditional journalist,
I'm coming in like no, we're
not doing this the regular news
way.
I don't care about
the 24-hour news cycle
and what's trending on Twitter.
Let's do more
long-form stories that
are going to matter later on.
So I use my documentary
film background
to create documentary
series, multimedia stories
because in this day
and age, not everyone's
going to read the text.
But you need something that's
going to go on social media,
grab their attention.
So we like to use audio, video,
all different types of mediums
to tell stories.
ANGELA FORD: Wow.
OK, well I think we
covered everything
that we wanted to
talk about today
and we can open it up to
questions if anybody has any.
AUDIENCE: As I sit here
and listen to you guys
both present, I'm
filled with goosebumps
in terms of the power of
both of your platforms
to tell news stories for the
African-American experience.
I want to thank you guys
for this presentation
and just really appreciate it.
Thank you.
ANGELA FORD: Thank you.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: How have sponsors
responded to your site?
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
Actually, very well.
I keep it real with people
when I'm selling The Tribe.
Nobody's going to tell
stories about black Chicago
like we can, until they
start hiring black people.
So that hasn't
happened, so we're
going to be your best
voice for telling stories
about black people.
Yeah, so they really
come to us because they
want to reach our audience.
I mean, black millennials
are coming into buying power,
everybody's interested in that.
So, yeah, people
really approach us.
AUDIENCE: Along those lines,
how can we best support you--
both of you-- and
your organizations?
ANGELA FORD: You go first.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: Money,
money is always the answer.
I wish there was another
answer I could give you,
but we have the creativity,
we have the education,
we have a conglomerate
of creatives
who are ready and can't
get hired at legacy papers,
so yeah.
If we have money, we
can tell more stories
and that is the best
way to help us out.
If we can talk afterwards
if you're interested.
ANGELA FORD: Oh my
gosh, I love her.
Because I want to
say, ditto to that.
But gosh, I just love these
young people because that said,
I think my generation would
have said the exact same thing
in so many more words.
I would have stretched
that out to about seven
or eight sentences.
But-- with my formal
education and all that--
but I think that's what we're
going to be reaching out
for that as well.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks
so much for being here.
What kind of conversations
are happening with teachers
and with the CPS
system to kind of help
with these gaps in the narrative
that you're talking about?
Because it's obviously such
a crucial piece of this.
ANGELA FORD: Well, I appreciate
you asking that because both
of my parents were teachers.
And so I know way more about
teaching than football,
but one of the things that
we're doing at The Obsidian
is we're going to be creating
educational content as well.
But the interesting thing
about education right
now is it has
gotten very narrow,
people are teaching to
very standardized systems.
And it doesn't
leave a lot of room
for extra curricula that way.
But the charter school
system is coming up
and even they, I've already
been talking to them,
it's just a very narrow space.
But we're working with
virtual reality and some
of all these other
things so that when
that relaxes a little
bit-- because I'm
excited that the places like
Google and these big tech firms
are moving away from
these traditional,
narrow requirements
and that's allowing
for a lot more creativity.
We feel like with
these platforms,
we can get the knowledge
and information out
even if it doesn't come through
organized curriculum systems.
So we're just going
to keep creating
and then you young people
just keep inventing.
Just when I figured
out this tool, now
everything is on the virtual.
So we're going to get it there.
And then we'll get the
information out there
because you guys are
taking in information
in so many different ways.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
Let me add on
to that because I love talking
to teachers about education.
I think we need to
totally reframe the way
that we teach about history.
And I always tell this story--
I remember being in about
seventh or eighth grade
and my social studies
teacher wrote on the board
in huge letters,
Manifest Destiny.
And we're literally
talking about the US
going through and
stealing everybody's land
and just massacring people.
And we call that section in
history Manifest Destiny.
So I need for teachers
to start teaching
from the point of
view of the oppressed
and if the title of
the text in history
sounds like a comic book,
then it's probably wrong.
And we need to like, reassess
what we're teaching our kids.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, first
of all, I want
to say that from my perspective,
you nailed it on football.
What's the problem?
That's what I see.
ANGELA FORD: Collision.
AUDIENCE: But
seriously, exactly.
I'm Maudelyne Ihejirika.
I'm both a columnist
for the Sun-Times
and president of the
National Association
of Black Journalists.
And I just want
to say that, more
of a comment than
a small question,
and that is that I'm blown away.
I'm blown away.
I've heard about your project,
I've read bits and pieces,
but today just sitting
there in the few minutes
that you went over
some of the photos,
you told me stories
I didn't even know.
And yeah, I think
I know everything.
But I'm saying as
black journalists
and as veterans, we think we
pretty much know the history,
but there were pieces
of history you told me--
just little small photos--
the one about the guy who--
Fred?
Is it Fred?
ANGELA FORD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Oh my god,
I've never heard of him.
I was like--
I made a note, go
look him up, you know?
ANGELA FORD: And
his grandson turned
those archives over
to Shorefront Legacy,
his grandson still
lives in Evanston
and turned that
archive over, yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's amazing.
And then, just to say,
Morgan, of course.
Hey Morgan.
I am so, so proud of Morgan and
she and Tiffany and her team,
they just are, they're stars
they're NABJ stars here
in Chicago.
The one thing I
wanted to ask you
is so, as I sat here
listening to it,
I was struck by how do I--
I mean, besides telling
the story of The Obsidian
Collective--
how do we share those photos?
I mean, in terms
of when you think
about copyright, and
like if the Sun-Times,
if I wanted to do a story with
a gallery of these photos,
how are they being
allowed to be shared?
ANGELA FORD: I'm glad
you asked that too.
So, we've got lawyers, right?
And so I've learned a
lot about copyright law,
but a big part of The
Obsidian Collection platform,
we're building a very
expensive website, yeah--
that is going to be a
quick access to licensing
and permissions, so that it's
going to rival the other stock
photo images out there, as
well as a platform for viewing
and pleasure and enjoyment.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANGELA FORD: But there
will be quick access
and that is a
revenue share model,
so that the owners retain
ownership and then can
monetize.
What it does is
it allows revenue
to go into these small archive
groups that need those dollars,
and then it makes it available
for you to tell the stories.
Because the Schomburg
library, which
gathered all of the
Harlem information--
the reason Harlem is
written more about
than Bronzeville
was, is because you
had access to the information.
The Schomburg actually
gathered up all the images
and then you could go in
there and license it and tell
all these stories.
That hasn't been nearly
as easy in Bronzeville.
I do the licensing and
permissions for the Chicago
Defender right now.
And we've negotiated with
movies, documentaries, books--
but it's very manual,
it's voluntary,
and it is not scalable.
So we're making that
as a revenue stream
for black legacy
newspapers that own
their archives, the
photographers, and the archive
groups.
OK good.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thank you ladies
so much for your information.
It's going to be
beneficial to all.
So, my comment slash question
is in the form of money,
since you mentioned that.
And so my question
is, have either
of you thought about any
type of fundraising efforts
in order to not only get your
information out there, but then
also collect funds
at the same time?
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
Right, The Tribe
is actually celebrating our
second anniversary right now.
So we'll be having a huge
fundraiser on April 12th.
So, yeah, you'll be getting
all of that information.
ANGELA FORD: Thanks, and
we don't have a fundraiser
scheduled, but we will.
It's going to be as new
collections join The Obsidian,
our hope is to, as
we welcome them,
to have a fundraiser
to celebrate.
Because the digitization
takes time, treasure, money,
all of those things.
So that's our
strategy, thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was
going to ask you,
you're here in Chicago so the
Chicago Defender is available.
But what about the other black
newspapers across the country?
Can you give us
an example of what
it's like going into
the bowels of whatever
to find this material?
And is some of it
destroyed, is it
salvageable at the
other newspapers,
say in Lincoln, Pennsylvania
or Amsterdam News in New York?
ANGELA FORD: Yeah, so that's
a phenomenal question.
When we started with The
Defender, the first thing I did
was start talking to
other black legacy papers,
just to kind of see where
they were so we could
mirror what they were doing.
And nobody was doing it.
As journalism
institutions have shrunk,
the first thing you kind of
put on the side is the archive
and you maintain the journalism.
And then when things are sold,
different people have them,
different people
feel they own them.
So we've got the lawyers
sorting all that out.
But we've got like
eight legacy newspapers
in the queue that want
to join The Obsidian.
But most philanthropy
is local, so in terms
of rolling them in and
getting them digitized,
those are very specific to
the local community aspects.
And we're looking at
partnering with local HBCUs
to partner with their
library science departments
and get some of
their labor going
and get this whole thing
kind of, this big obsidian
circle, which is the logo--
obsidian circle.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: I can
add on to that a little bit--
ANGELA FORD: Oh, sure.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
--about archiving.
Again, we do see The
Tribe as a future source
for these types of materials
because so many newspapers
and publications have laid off
photographers and people who
take videos and
things like that.
And a lot of
millennials and youth,
we get our news from our
phones and from really kind
of like tabloid sites on
Instagram and Twitter,
like The Shade Room
and things like that,
where it's not real news and
it's people just aggregating
materials.
So it's very
important for us to be
very persistent in going
out and taking new images
and capturing what
Chicago is today.
ANGELA FORD: That's
one thing I love
about you guys is you're not
just aggregating entertainment
and just kind of recirculating.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON: We
actually make a point,
we don't aggregate at all.
We don't go and say, oh,
this is trending right now,
we're going to just
like copy and paste what
these people said.
Because our whole
thing is, since we
have a small staff is like,
if this story is already
being told, there's no
reason for us to tell it too.
We need to go in and
tell the stories that
are not being told.
AUDIENCE: That's a great point.
With this being
Black History Month,
and I think it's
important, like you
said-- you need to tell
the stories that are not
being told.
My name is [? Kristal ?]
[? Allison, ?] and I tell
people I'm first generation
great migration to Chicago
by way of Arkansas
and Tennessee.
And in that process, I've been--
Angela and I have known each
other since high school.
And we've talked
a lot about this.
ANGELA FORD: I look amazing.
AUDIENCE: And we talked a great
deal about this and I shared,
I think that what she's
doing is phenomenal.
And I just learned
about The Tribe today.
Angela may have
mentioned it and some
of our other conversations.
But when the movie
"The Butler" came out
and I was at the
advanced screening,
and it was done by Lee Daniels.
So they're talking
about it because they
didn't know about that story.
So I was there for
the Q&A, et cetera,
and I said, wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute--
the black man that was
in the White House,
he was the highest
level executive
in the White House at
that time, who happened
to be one of my relatives.
Everett Frederic Morrow.
Under the Eisenhower
administration,
he was the first
African American
to have the highest level
position in the White House.
When Obama ran for
president, then
they talked about
it here and there.
And by eBay, because I like
to look stuff up as well,
I realized that he
had written a book
and it was entitled "Black
Man in the White House."
And he chronicled a lot of
the things that were going on
and a lot of the
involvement that he had.
So, as I spoke to
Lee Daniels, I was
going to like, in
telling that story,
you also need to
tell this story too.
Because he was a
Republican and he
was a lawyer and in
addition, his sister
also made some major
inroads as well.
But it was kind of
like, I'm learning
like I didn't know this.
As well as I'm learning
a lot of other things,
I didn't know one of my great
uncles was a Tuskegee Airmen.
He's going to be 99
years old this year.
So I think that what you
guys are doing on both sides,
on the millennial side and
on his side, that there are
stories to be told,
there are photographs
that are out there that are in
people's personal collections.
And so, I'm not sure
if I missed part of it,
but what are you doing to get
personal collections included
in your archives as well?
Or how do you communicating
that this exists?
Because some people where,
as they're leaving us,
the photographs are being
buried, thrown away,
or kind of locked in
somebody's photo book,
and not being told about.
ANGELA FORD: Well, a personal
archive collection actually
kind of falls under
the category for us
as a small community archive.
So when The Obsidian first
joined Google Arts and Culture,
we put out a press release
and we got a ton of pickup
because everybody was just
so excited about that.
And one of the phone
calls I got was
a woman who had inherited her
dad's collection of 300,000
photos that included 1960s
Motown, which is gold,
and 1960s Chicago,
which was awesome too.
And so many times,
people inherit
these wonderful collections
of black legacy,
but they definitely want
to retain ownership.
And most people think, well,
I've got to stand up a museum,
I've got to create
my own foundation,
I've got to replicate
this entire thing,
and what we're offering instead
is a platform for some of that.
But at the same
time, we're going
to be having workshops and
symposiums on how to properly
store and keep your own archives
and also what's valuable,
what's valuable to
the world, and what's
valuable to you, which may
be two different things.
What happens when people leave
things with a collection?
What happens when
people leave them
with a museum or a university?
So we're going to do
a lot of education
around protecting
black history as well.
So our goal isn't to build
another black Smithsonian,
even though that
place is amazing.
We're going to be focusing
more on digital outreach
even though we will
have a location.
AUDIENCE: I mean, I think that
there's another museum that's
in the process of being
built, I forget where
it's going to be built at.
ANGELA FORD: Well,
there's always museums,
I mean we're not
cornering that space.
AUDIENCE: So there's
always room for,
I think, for additional stuff.
Because just as that museum
has a lot of wonderful stuff
in there, as I was told,
they couldn't get everything
in there.
So there's, again,
more stories that are
out there to be told as well.
So it's good to see that they're
both platforms or forums here
to provide that as a
mechanism for learning more
because I think it is important
that we're taught who we are
and learn more about ourselves.
ANGELA FORD: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
all very much coming.
And I want to ask you guys, like
you all really inspired me here
today, I liked
listening to this a lot,
and it was really interesting.
I'm wondering, is fine art
ever going to be part of that?
I'm 50, so I'm like in between
the millennial or whatever.
But I had my first piece in
the museum when I was 10.
So I've seen--
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
You said fine arts?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What about like Richard Hunt
and Kerry James Marshall and all
those people.
Like, they did some really
cool, interesting shit back
in the day.
MORGAN ELISE JOHNSON:
On The Tribe,
we recognize that news isn't the
only way to capture our story.
So we have a section on the
site, if you go to the top,
there's a tab that
says The Works.
And it's just a space
for creative works
of many different mediums
from like short films
to photography, art, so yeah.
So we open that up for people
to submit that type of material
to us.
AUDIENCE: Cool, all right.
That's good to know.
I'll check it out.
ANGELA FORD: Yeah,
so we haven't been
able to get into the
fine art space yet
because that's a different
set of legal questions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANGELA FORD: So
right now, we've got
images and who owns the
image, but projecting art
isn't something
we've gotten to yet.
AUDIENCE: It's some
really incredible artists.
ANGELA FORD: There's some
beautiful things out there,
I agree with you.
AUDIENCE: Like all over
Chicago, old stuff too.
ANGELA FORD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Again, if we could
give Morgan and Angela one more
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]